>>Reto: Alright.
Good afternoon once again, once again.
To the Friday app review.
Hopefully this time coming to you with slightly
fewer video artifacts than ten minutes ago.
So like I said, today we're gonna have a look
at some notes ads, uh, notes apps, in the
time we have remaining.
But we're gonna kick off by talking to Paul
Carff, inventor of the KegDroid, and find
out a little bit more about that product.
So you wanna tell us a little bit about Kegdroid
Paul?
>>Paul: Sure guys.
Thanks for having me here.
And for the opportunity to share this wonderful
little toy that we have.
Back in January we were at CES.
At the consumer electronics show in Vegas.
And as some of what developers do, sitting
around a table hugging some drinks.
Sort of talking and brainstorming.
We had this idea, we have fun with using our
Android technology and one of my favorite
pastimes is brewing and drinking beer.
>>Reto: Nice.
>>Paul: So I, in my garage, kind of pulled
together some parts and pieces and started
tinkering with it.
And actually had the idea of building an actual
Android model.
To dispense my beer.
And of course it wouldn't be enough just to
do that, I wanted it do it automatically.
>>Reto: Absolutely.
>>Paul: So that's kind of what inspired it.
>>Fred: that's great.
>>Reto: Alright, so tell us a little bit about
the setup.
So we can see that there's, I think a Motorola
Xoom on the front of the KegDroid there.
So, how does that work?
What does that bring to the equation?
>>Paul: Well, the idea is that you wanna let
people know what beer is available.
And so what I've done with the Xoom here is,
it kind of acts as a kiosk mode.
So it will tell you what beers are available
and that's how you interact with the device.
So the first thing you do is, we currently
are using an NFC reader that's connected to
an arduino that's inside the body of the Android.
And then you have the Android tablet.
What you see now is a big banner on here,
telling you to scan your badge.
>>Fred: OK.
>>Paul: and what that's telling you to do
is, you need to have an NFC badge of some
kind.
You can use the standard sticker kind that
just has a tag number on it.
Or what we're having fun doing is using our
Android phones that have the NFC built into
it.
So as long as I unlock my phone and hold it
over the scanner, you'll see that it unlocks
the tab button.
>>Reto: Ah, nice.
>>Paul: And now you can interact with is.
>>Fred: so the tablet talks to the arduino,
using ADK?
Right?
>>Paul: Using ADK, absolutely.
>>Fred: Yeah.
OK.
>>Reto: Perfect.
And so what happens when you, when you actually
select a beer, one of the two options.
What happens then?
Does that still get controlled by the Xoom
and the ADK?
>>Paul: So now that you're, at this point
you're interacting with the Android application
and on the Xoom, and when you tap on one of
the beers that are available, you get a drop
down menu.
And you can pick either the size of beer,
or the size of pour.
By default I have these set up for a two,
an eight, and a 12 ounce pour.
You can cancel your interaction and it resets
it.
Or you've actually selected the beer size
that you want, and then when you select pour,
that actually opens up, that sends a message
to the arduino, that then tells the, it actually
resets the flow meter and it opens up a solenoid
valve to start the pour.
>>Reto: Very nice.
So it's a totally automated process at that
point.
You just scan your badge, put your glass underneath
the spigot, and wait for delicious beer.
>>Paul: Yeah, and I think it's better than
talking about it, maybe I should show you.
>>Reto: Yeah.
I think you should.
>>Fred: Yeah, I think you need a couple more
testers.
For this program.
>>Reto: [laughs]
>>Paul: And I will say that DevRellers are
totally wonderful.
Because I have no end of having, when I need
testing done, they're always there to step
up to the plate.
>>Reto: [laughs] You are able to find volunteers.
That's surprising.
People are often so reluctant to test apps.
But.
>>Paul: This one here gets good, lots of good
testing.
And we've made a lot of good changes and we
now know that we have a lot more changes to
make.
>>Reto: Very cool.
>>Paul: But let's go ahead and show you what
this looks like.
>>Reto: Yeah, let's check it out.
>>Paul: when you're actually pouring a beer.
So I'm gonna go ahead and open up the tap.
We just keep these closed that way that nobody
accidentally goes by and does anything.
But when you open the tap, nothing happens
because it's waiting for the solenoid valve.
So I'm gonna pick my eight ounce pour.
And I'm just holding my glass here and I'll
start pouring.
And what you're going to see is a dialog pops
up and it actually shows you the progress
of the pour.
It's calibrated so if you do a two ounce pour,
the dialog does a full glass for two ounces.
If you pick 12 ounces, it'll flow according
to your 12 ounce pour so it's fairly accurate.
So I hit pour, and it starts pouring the beer,
you see the dialog going.
And then when it's done, it shuts off the
valve.
So the flow stops, the dialog disappears,
the system resets, and it's ready for the
next person to scan their badge and enjoy
their beer.
>>Reto: Very nice.
>>Fred: Great.
>>Reto: So that's a pretty awesome use of
all the technology.
Have you thought about what the next steps
might be, apart from different beers, of course?
>>Paul: yeah, actually, this is set up for
two beers on one device.
And what happens now if you think about it,
you have two taps, but you can only do one
at a time.
So if you actually have a professional system,
you know each tap should be independent and
work that way.
And right now it only, you can do one at a
time.
So we're looking at, and also this kiosk mode
and this interaction here, to me is kind of
limiting.
It's a very closed system.
I'll put it this way.
It's kind of all enclosed.
What I do actually do at this moment is when
I complete the transaction I collect the data,
from, I know which Android you were on.
I know which beer you picked and I know how
much beer you poured.
That gets sent back to an app engine app.
And I actually collect that data and for Google
IO at the after-hours party, we had three
of these units with all automated like this.
And I was collecting the statistics and I
can actually map out on the floor where each
Android was.
I had an app that would just highlight where
each Android, KegDroid was at.
And then how much, how many beers had been
poured.
How many gallons had been poured.
>>Reto: Wow, excellent.
>>Paul: so it was just some fun statistics.
So we want to, kind of expand that even more
now, where maybe you have an app on your phone,
through a registration process you get authorized
to actually talk to the Android.
Or get a beer from the Android.
And then when you order from it you can find
out what beers are on tap all through your
phone.
And then you kind of smooth the transition
process here at some point.
Which gives you a scalable system because
we have one of these in our Mountain View
office here.
We could have one of them in our London office.
And if you go out there, and you're authorized
to drink from that KegDroid, you just order
it from your app and walk up to it and get
your beer.
>>Reto: Very nice.
So you could end up having quite a sophisticated
system.
Depending on obviously the distribution of
KegDroids.
But you could have your favorite beers and
be alerted when there's a place nearby where
a KegDroid is, has exactly what you wanna
drink on tap.
>>Paul: exactly.
>>Fred: Distributive system right there.
>>Paul: It would be kind of fun, too, that,
let's say you're not a normal user of it,
but maybe one of your friends can give you
a free beer token.
>>Reto: um-hum.
>>Paul: That says "Hey, you can have a beer
from this KegDroid when you happen to come
by."
>>Fred: I thought we had all you can drink
in this office.
>>Reto: That's a dangerous system.
I think everything needs to be approved by
Billy, right?
He gives you a beer token.
>>Paul: Well, there you go.
We could actually say that the KegDroid doesn't
open up office hours until four pm.
>>Reto: That's probably a very wise idea.
[laughs]
>>Fred: There you go.
There you go.
>>Ian: But Billy will never approve that.
Why don't you try Nan?
[laughter]
By the way, Paul, I smell a Kickstarter project
right now.
>>Paul: MMMMmmm.
>>Reto: This is true.
It wouldn't be the first Android Kickstarter
project, that's for sure.
>>Ian: Yeah.
>>Fred: Hey Paul, to date how many gallons
of beers have been served?
>>Paul: Well
>>Fred: Do you have any insight?
>>Paul: Well I'll tell you what I know from
IO.
We had at least 670 pours.
The network there, as many of you guys know,
who have gone to Google IO, the network is
not always that great.
>>Reto: [laughs]
>>Paul: So I think I missed a number of transactions
but you know, at least 670 beers.
And everybody was selecting the 12 ounce pours.
So you can calculate how many gallons of beer.
>>Fred: Right.
Wow.
Very cool.
>>Reto: So, wait, wait.
Oh, I mean this is a review show.
So I feel like I need to dive into this a
little more.
Are you saying that?
>>Paul: Absolutely.
>>Reto: If you don't have internet connectivity
then you lose those transactions?
>>Paul: In the current design yes.
And that's going to be one of the first changes
I make.
>>Reto: Absolutely.
>>Paul: What I'm gonna do for the next round
is we'll have all the transactions recorded
locally on the database and then have a service
running in the background synchronizing that
database to app [ indistinct ]
>>Reto: Excellent.
In face I have a Google IO talk which can
give you some hints as to exactly how you
could do that.
>>Fred: [laughs]
>>Paul: Really?
I'll have to [indistinct]
>>Reto: Oh.
I see.
My mic is being disrespectful.
Give me one moment.
[mic sounds]
Hopefully that's a lot better?
Excellent.
We've got big Ian Lewis behind the producer
controls today.
Making sure that we don't sound or look terrible.
Or at least not more so than we normally would.
>>Ian: I resent that adjective.
[laughter]
>>Reto: nonetheless.
OK.
Paul, so I guess, thank you, for giving us
that, taking the time.
And making the sacrifice of having to pour
and drink that beer before four o'clock.
I know that's a tough life.
>>Paul: I would tell you, rest assured that
no beer was harmed in the testing.
There was a lot of water that went through
this system so that we didn't waste it.
>>Reto: Excellent.
>>Fred: It worked.
>>Paul: But when it came down to it.
>>Reto: What, I feel as part of the Friday
review, I would be remiss if I didn't ask
what are the two beers you have, or one or
two beers that you have on tap today?
>>Paul: Well currently what we have on tap
is, what I'm drinking here now is Dogfish
Head 90 minute IPA.
And the other beer we have on tap is from
21st Amendment.
It is Monk's blood.
>>Fred: Very nice choice.
>>Paul: which is a very interesting Belgian
ale.
Strong Belgian ale.
Looks almost like a Porter but not quite.
It's very spicy.
Very interesting.
>>Ian: You know, Paul, we don't usually encourage
people to disturb us here in the studio when
we're recording.
But if you do happen to be passing by, you
know, don't be afraid to knock.
And deliver us something.
[laughter]
>>Paul: I'll see if, we'll see what happens.
>>Reto: [laughs]
>>Fred: We'd like to be your testers.
>>Reto: We'd look forward to it.
But, thanks Paul.
We should probably move on, 'cause we lost
a bit of time at the beginning.
>>Paul: Alright.
Cheers guys.
Thank you.
>>Reto: So.
Ah, thank you.
And congrats.
>>Fred: Thanks Paul.
>>Reto: Alright.
Excellent.
So that was KegDroid.
>>Fred: Ready for, ready for some note-taking
time?
>>Reto: Let's have a look at some note-taking
apps.
But before we get too deeply into the apps
themselves I just wanna do a little bit of
housekeeping this week.
So I wanna do things a little bit different.
So as many of you know, we've sort of been
experimenting with the formats of all of our
shows.
Particularly the Friday reviews, both apps
and games.
And so what we're trying to do, so the point
behind what we're doing here is to try and
come up with ways to be able to share with
developers some tips that we come across when
we look at different apps.
So a big part of what we do on a daily basis
is check out people's apps.
Provide feedback and give them some assistance
to help make them better.
So the Friday review is really about trying
to take that and share that with you guys.
So when we're picking apps, we're looking
for things which both are really good, which
show a great example of how to do things.
But also apps which do some things wrong.
Specifically so that you guys can learn from
those mistakes and we can sort of tell you
guys all in one go and then hopefully a lot
of apps will be able to benefit from that.
So to try and make that process a little bit
more streamlined, we've always sort of used
the voting within Moderator as something of
a guide to get an idea of what people want,
rather than a strict ordering of the apps
that we're gonna look at.
>>Fred: Hmm.
>>Reto: we're gonna take that a little bit
further now and we're gonna try and do these
themed shows every weeks.
This week we're looking at notes.
Next week we're looking at news apps.
The week after that, podcasting apps.
And I think the next schedule beyond that
is what was it?
Do you remember what we decided on?
>>Fred: I don't, but we'll see.
>>Reto: Do you remember Ian?
>>Fred: We'll find out.
>>Ian: Um.
Yeah I believe it's news, followed by recipes,
then podcast.
>>Fred: Oh yes.
Recipes.
>>Reto: Podcast was last.
OK, so yes, recipes.
>>Fred: Recipes.
Lifestyle applications.
[dog barking in background]
>>Reto: so if you have an app in any of those
three categories, go to the Moderator page.
We will have links to it on the event and
in the Google plus stream after this.
Follow Android Developers for the links.
And put them in there.
And we will look at the votes.
But to be perfectly honest.
We're gonna take a quick look at all of those
apps and try and find the ones which are the
most interesting or which do interesting things.
Or even just things which we find we can use
as examples for everything else.
So by all means vote, but don’t' be offended
if we don't pick all of the apps specifically
based on those vote results.
Alright, so.
>>Fred: Alright.
>>Reto: Enough housekeeping.
So let's look at some apps.
Oh, what have we got?
So we've got three note taking apps which
hopefully we'll get a chance to look at.
Notes.
Let's see, you can probably read it here.
Notes N Share.
Note.
And Papyrus.
So let's get started with Notes N Share.
Open that up on the phone.
Alright.
Perfect.
Actually go, oops, a little bit further over.
Excellent.
>>Fred: Perfect.
>>Reto: OK, so this is an app which is using
sort of, a non-standard style if you will.
So It looks like they've gone with sort of
your standard notebook like, could be a Moleskine
or something like that, where you've got your
grid on the background.
And able to take notes on top.
And so the entire UI is based around that.
Now, the, there's two things I wanna highlight
here right off the bat.
Is that you've got your own sort of custom
header here for notes n share.
But there's still the application title bar
on top of that.
And so, to me, I think that that sort of detracts
from it.
So you've kind of got this full screen experience.
You've got this really custom UI.
Go all the way.
There's not need to have that extra title
bar on top.
So right off the back I would say to hide
that.
Same with the menu button.
Oooh.
It's a menu button of shame.
>>Fred: Uh-oh
>>Reto: Let me just scroll this up here.
So you've got a menu button but it doesn't
do anything.
So, I would, oh, hello.
Here we have some of Paul's work.
>>Fred: Beer.
Some, conduct some testing.
>>Reto: We can do some taste testing here.
It's a bit of Friday games review on the Friday
review.
>>Fred: That's right.
>>Reto: So we at least need to test.
So cheers.
>>Fred: Cheers, Reto.
Cheers, Ian.
Hm.
Pretty good.
>>Reto: That's not bad.
Perfect.
OK.
So, moving on.
So we've got a menu button of shame.
Remove the menu button of shame.
Please.
>>Fred: Oh.
There.
>>Reto: It doesn't do anything so it doesn't
need to be onscreen.
>>Fred: And removing it is really easy.
You just need to set the target SDK level
to anything above 11.
>>Reto: Exactly.
>>Fred: Yup.
>>Reto: and so nothing else will change.
You won't lose anything else.
And particularly for this app.
It has to be 15?
>>Fred: 15
>>Reto: Interesting.
You'd have to set it at 15.
>>Fred: It has to be 15 now.
>>Reto: alright.
>>Fred: 15.
15 it is.
>>Reto: 15 it is.
And in fact, this is a good tip.
For the most part, you'll be wanting to test
all your apps against the latest framework
release.
And the target APK, the target API should
always be the latest release.
Which is in fact 16.
These days.
So as soon as something like, as soon as a
new release comes out, you should really make
it a matter of priority to, you know, open
up Eclipse or IntelliJ or whatever you're
using to do your development.
And test it out.
Change the target SDK level to the maximum.
And see what changes.
Ideally nothing should.
For the most part things should just continue
to work the same that they did.
Once you have that confidence, then you can
release it that way.
And then you have to take advantage of things
like the more native look and feel.
And everything will look and behave the way
it should on new devices.
So these days in particular, we really wanna
see people have a great experience on the
Nexus 7.
And so we want you to target that latest SDK
version.
And you lose things like legacy menu buttons
and other things like that.
>>Fred: Right.
Better in general make your apps look more
modern.
>>Reto: Yeah.
Exactly.
It's nice, right?
You want your apps to, how good is that?
You change one number in your manifest file?
And suddenly your app looks cleaner and fresher,
more modern.
So.
>>Fred: Right.
>>Reto: Kind of a no brainer.
>>Fred: and the other thing I wanna point
out is the button that's right above the button
of shame.
It's
>>Reto: Ah.
It's my button of hate.
[laughs]
>>Fred: It spells e-x-i-t.
Exit.
>>Reto: Ah, the exit button.
Let me see what the exit button does.
Interesting.
Now, let me see, what does the back button
do?
Now you see how those do exactly the same
thing?
One of them is unnecessary.
>>Fred: Why bother?
>>Reto: and you can only get rid of one of
these buttons.
So now if you could choose between the exit
and the back button.
That may be some sort of decision you have
to make.
But you can't make that choice, right.
The back button will always be there.
The exit button is entirely redundant.
I have a very long blog post in which I rant
about this for several pages.
If you're interested you can check that out.
But for the most part what it really all boils
down to is that there is no need to have an
exit button.
Now, there's a lot of people which will argue
with me.
They will point out all the reasons why as
a user they wanna have an exit button.
And I understand where you're coming from.
The thing to remember is, it's totally ambiguous,
because you as a user have no idea what the
developer has done to implement that exit
button.
So maybe it does what you want.
Maybe it turns off all the services, removes
all of the alarms and exits the app.
Or, more likely, all it's gonna do is call
finish.
And calling finish is exactly what happens
when you hit the back button on your main
activity.
So it's effectively doing the same thing.
And the difference here as a user is, you
don't know what.
It's an ambiguous button.
It doesn't have any clear directive to know
what's actually happening.
So I'm gonna stop ranting before I go on.
No exit buttons.
Alright, so let's have a look at some of the
functionality.
So.
>>Fred: Let's take some notes.
>>Reto: yeah.
Indeed.
But again, I'm gonna interrupt myself.
So half of these things these three button
buttons, are kind of unnecessary to have on
the main screen.
So right here, like, I've opened this up for
the first time and I have three, six, what
is that nine?
Eight or nine different options.
All of which I have to read and understand
before I
>>Fred: Looks pretty crowded, right?
>>Reto: Yeah.
It's like, oh I wanna, I downloaded an app.
I just want to take some notes.
And now I need to read all of those buttons
to see which one of those is gonna let me
do that.
You know, text notes, hand notes, audio notes,
my diary, to do list.
>>Fred: especially for things such as about,
or help.
Chances are you're gonna use it once in the
lifetimes of the application.
>>Reto: Yeah.
Exactly.
>>Fred: So your point is, Reto, is to hide
those buttons.
Somewhere.
>>Reto: Oh.
I like that.
Hide those buttons.
Yeah.
>>Fred: Yeah.
>>Reto: Put them behind the menu.
You know, you can have, you can have your
own sort of action bar sort of scenario here.
So you've got your own custom header up at
the top . and I like that.
But it would be nice to have a menu button.
Sort of overflow menu.
>>Fred: Definitely.
>>Reto: Sort of over on the right there.
>>Fred: Yeah.
>>Reto: And you can hide all this stuff.
At least the bottom two.
Well.
The second bottom two.
[laughs]
>>Fred: I'd say, remove the exit button.
>>Reto: Yeah.
>>Fred: Probably hide about and help.
>>Reto: Yeah, exactly.
>>Fred: on your mobile phone
>>Reto: Yeah.
Exactly.
So OK, so let's have a look.
So, OK, one thing I do wanna point out is
right away is that so these custom controls,
but you can see here they've actually implemented
the button behavior properly.
I'm a big fan of this, right.
>>Fred: Oh.
So there are states.
>>Reto: so there are states.
>>Fred: Differentiations.
>>Reto: So you can see when it's pressed and
what thing you've pressed.
This is fantastic.
A lot of people building custom controls forget
to implement those state indicators.
And it makes a huge difference.
So yeah.
This is good.
I'm a fan of this.
>>Fred: Right.
>>Reto: Alright, text notes.
>>Fred: By the way, I wonder if they implemented
in a focused state.
Or not.
>>Reto: That's a good question, I can't
>>Fred: We don't have a device to verify that.
>>Reto: So that's a good point, actually,
that Fred makes.
Is that one of the things that you wanna make
sure you do if you are doing states, is have
the focused state.
So if you're never getting through it using
a D pad or
>>Fred: Or Google TV
>>Reto: Yeah, or Google TV.
>>Fred: So there are essentially three states.
Natural, normal?
Are we calling it normal?
>>Reto: Yeah, I think so.
>>Fred: Normal, focused, and you know, pressed.
>>Reto: Exactly.
So make sure you do all of them so that, and
that helps for accessibility as well.
So it's really a good idea.
Alright, so we're in the notes.
And we can just start typing.
So again we're using this, no, I can't talk
and type at the same time.
Alright.
Nice.
So you can see here, move this down slightly.
We're just basically using this notepad paradigm.
So things look like a notepad.
Which is interesting.
I think there's a little debate over whether
or not that's sort of the best approach on
mobile.
But it's in keeping with the style of the
rest of their app, right?
And it doesn't seem to be slowing things down.
So, I'd say that's reasonable.
Again, I'd say this title bar here, is somewhat
redundant.
You may wanna have some sort of action bar
so that you can return to home.
Or have the overflow menu.
But generally speaking just having the standard
one makes it look out of place.
>>Fred: Yeah.
Definitely.
And you probably wanna stick your logo in
the action bar.
>>Reto: Yeah, exactly.
>>Fred: To preserve your brand identity so
that you're gonna know, hey, they may have
three or four different note taking apps on
their phone.
And that, you know, you can help yourself
stand out a little bit.
>>Reto: Exactly.
You know, let people know who you are.
So you take the opportunity to brand yourself
a little.
So, OK.
So now we have a menu button that is not shameful.
In that it actually does something.
>>Fred: [laughs]
>>Reto: But it is a little shameful in the
way that it does it.
So first off check out the design guide on
the developer at Android.com/design site.
And it'll tell you what the right way to build
icons for your menu are.
Spoilers.
They are grayscale.
They are flat.
So all of these which have colors and sort
of non sort of flat styling, look weird.
Like to me this just looks wrong.
[laughs] 'Cause they're too big and they're
the wrong color and for some reason all of
the writing is in caps which I can't really
understand why.
So yeah.
I mean all of this is summarized in the developer
design site.
So basically just check that out.
And you'll wanna modify these so that they're
consistent.
Anything which is part of the system framework,
so bringing up menus or action bars or anything
like that.
You want it to look like the system does.
You don't want to break users out of this
thing where now I'm looking at this going
"Oh wait, that doesn't look like I expected."
Save button.
Should be redundant.
So you should build in something here to make
sure that you can never lose data.
So I don't wanna have to hit menu save every
time I change something to make sure I don't
lose it if my phone turns off or if I exit
the app or something.
>>Fred: Or if you get a phone call.
>>Reto: Or if I get a phone call.
Exactly.
>>Fred: it would totally suck if you lose
your content.
That way.
>>Reto: That's right.
So if every time I typed something.
I mean this in particular.
You're talking about text.
>>Fred: Mm-hm.
>>Reto: so it's not a huge amount of data.
You're not gonna have sort of a huge lag from
having to save things.
So yeah.
Definitely make "save" happen automatically.
Let's have a look.
We've got more so, again,
>>Fred: More text only icons.
>>Reto: Every time you see things in caps,
it's like shouting.
It's the same as email, right?
So stop shouting at me.
So we've got text, speech,
>>Fred: [mumbling]
>>Reto: share, share loads the standard share
intent which is nice.
>>Fred: That's great.
That's great.
>>Reto: Absolutely.
Let's have a look, we'll go back.
>>Fred: Let's go back without explicitly hitting
save and see what happens after this screen.
>>Reto: That's a good idea.
Alright.
So we're gonna go back out of this.
So, are you sure you wanna quit without saving
your text not.
No.
>>Fred: That just disrupts the work.
I mean.
>>Reto: I just wanna hit back and go back.
So this should be like, at the first point,
I'd say why don't you just let me save it
here?
Like do you wanna save?
>>Fred: It's implicit.
>>Reto: Or do you wanna quit?
>>Fred: Or have it implicit I would say.
>>Reto: Even.
No, even, yeah, that's exactly right Fred.
Like have it implicit.
I hate dialogs almost as much as I hate exit
buttons.
So I don't wanna have this dialog asking me
to make a decisions.
I just, the reason I came back because I'm
about to get into the car and drive off.
I don't want to have to decide on this dialog.
So make it go away.
And save it automatically.
Even before hit exit.
I hit, look,
>>Fred: Sure.
>>Reto: The back button should always do something.
So that should at this point dismiss this
dialog.
Hitting back and having nothing change is
just not right at all.
So I'm gonna say yes.
Let's have a quick look through these.
'cause we've spent far too much time on this
already.
So this looks like drawing.
Which is nice.
It would be nice if this supported multitouch.
Which it doesn't right now.
So that's something to consider.
So, again, same general feedback as last time.
Although this time you've got the camera,
try and refocus.
But you've got the text here, for the menu
items here is lower case except if you go
into more and then it's upper.
Well, no, it's correct here.
>>Fred: But from the other menu, from the
previous thing, it was all caps.
>>Reto: so this is the right approach.
But again, you've got some issues with the
actual icons.
And again, with the saving as well.
Audio notes I'm gonna presume is going to
let us record something.
OK, so we're gonna record something here.
Hit stop.
Play.
[app plays back Reto's last sentence]
Don't know if you guys could here that but
it played it back so that's nice.
Again here we have some inconsistency.
So you're using sort of the standard buttons
where as with everything else you've got your
own custom UI.
So I'd modify this to try and use that same
approach.
And same here.
You've got save and open on screen.
And the other items they're in the menu so
again, sort of choose one way and go with
that.
Menu button of shame.
Ah, alright so, quick look through these.
So you've got diary which is just a specific
and to-do list which look like they're sort
of specific implementations.
Alright, we're gonna have a look at the other
ones as well.
'cause we do wanna do more than one app.
So that was interesting.
So the general feel there was try and build
a notes app which looks like your notepad
that you would have in paper.
Now I have a gap here, and sorry, Ian.
>>Ian: Oh yea, Reto, I just wanted to let
you know that I now have a camera, too.
And I
>>Reto: Awesome
>>Ian: and also that on the live stream there's
several people commenting that not only is
the focus on our little overhead webcam really
annoying,
>>Fred: Yeah, glare probably
>>Ian: You have some reflections.
It would help if you moved it to the middle.
But it would help actually even more if you
could switch over to your tablet if any of
these support tablet, especially since we
love tablet so much.
>>Reto: that's a good point.
>>Ian: and then we could get a really clean
picture.
>>Reto: Nice, we shall do exactly that.
And now that you are on camera, people can
decide for themselves whether the previously
stated adjective is appropriate or not.
[laughter]
>>Ian: It's not true
>>Fred: awesome.
>>Reto: OK.
Thank you for that feed back.
OK, so I have a gap here in the middle.
And that is for an app called ToteNotes.
Which we were gonna take a look at but I couldn’t
because it was not supported by any of the
devices that I currently use.
Now that is a fairly strong comment.
Because I own a lot of devices.
But I think the only device which I could
find on the list which I have ever used was
the T Mobile Galaxy Nexus.
All of the tablets, the Verizon version of
the Galaxy Nexus wasn't supported.
So I'm not sure exactly what you guys are
doing to filter which apps are available.
But I think you've gone a little bit far.
So generally speaking, this is something which
we try and encourage people to find out, to
try and make sure that that list of devices
where your app isn't available is as small
as possible.
Or, to put it in slightly more positive terms,
make your app as available on as many different
devices as you can.
So look at the permissions.
Look at the implied users feature, which,
first permissions you're gonna use.
And make sure that that's not blocking out
too much of your potential audience.
Alright.
>>Fred: Except for, just wanna add that if
the developer of Tote Notes is online, feel
free to join us.
I'd be very curious to find out the motivation
behind that.
>>Reto: yeah absolutely.
Let us know.
If you're even aware of this.
>>Fred: Mm-hmm.
>>Reto: Or if you're just like "I don't get
many downloads and I don't know why."
Um, OK
>>Fred: or you have too many downloads and
you wanna severely limit.
>>Reto: [chuckles] Exactly.
>>Ian: Um, this might be a good time to mention
two other things.
Reto, your radio should be on the table, so
we get every now and then you'll gesticulate
and we'll get a little bit of audio.
>>Reto: Every once in a while I'll gesticulate.
I gesticulate more often than not.
You guys just can't see it.
Because it's all happening off camera.
>>Ian: the other thing is, our on air sign
needs to be tilted a little bit so it's not
reflecting.
Uh.
Yeah.
>>Reto: Oh, wow, I can get it completely right
if I work hard.
There you go.
>>Ian: Wow, it's, it's, yeah, yeah, you got
it.
There you go.
Gotta work on it, but there you go.
>>Reto: [laughs]
>>Ian: It hurts.
>>Fred: [unintelligible] from you.
>>Ian: We are so professional it's unbelievable.
>>Reto: It is truly unbelievable.
How professional we are.
>>Fred: Yes.
A team of production staff here.
>>Reto: Some interns are gonna get fired.
Unfortunately we don't have any interns working
on this, so that's gonna make it a hard choices
as to who it's gonna be.
Let's have a look.
What have we got next on your home screen.
Is it Note?
>>Fred: Yeah, let's switch to the tablet.
>>Reto: Fire up Note.
>>Fred: Note.
Let's go.
Alright, it pops up a keyboard immediately.
And it's got an overall light theme with the
action bar
>>Reto: So this is a
>>Fred: With a text typing area that you can
input your text.
>>Reto: Yep.
Very sparse.
Kind of the opposite approach to that last
app, in there.
>>Fred: Yeah.
>>Reto: There's nothing on screen and even
the action bar is sort of light gray backgrounds
around white.
>>Fred: so I'm gonna start typing something.
Um.
Dismiss my keyboard, type something by
>>Reto: This is my test.
>>Fred: Oh, OK, this is my test.
And on the right hand side of the action bar
there are a few menu items but based on the
design of the menu items, they are kind of,
they lack the contrast.
It's not apparent to me that oh, you have
a plus sign and a folder icon.
I would recommend increasing the contrast
of these icons.
>>Reto: Mmm.
>>Fred: possibly based on the design guidelines.
>>Reto: Mm.
I like the fact that you've tried to keep
it as unobtrusive as possible.
And you obviously used low contrast for that
reason.
But if it is an action, if it is something
you want people to do, I think maybe a little
bit more
>>Fred: Right.
>>Reto: Let me have a look.
I wanna check one thing so.
Ah, good.
So they've got the proper hints.
>>Fred: They have the accessibility.
>>Reto: Accessibility hints, nice.
>>Fred: Or imagine if I turn on voice, what
it would talk to me?
>>Reto: I would expect so, yeah.
>>Fred: That's pretty awesome.
Good job.
>>Reto: [laughs] So nicely done.
Huh?
>>Fred: So there's an overflow menu.
I think they appropriately hid "about" and
"export" menu items.
In the overflow menu.
>>Reto: So there's something I noticed when
you first loaded it up, it said that you had
to hit this to save.
So, and this is my, so you have to save it
once and then it will auto save.
So that's, interesting.
There's two problems I have with that.
First of all, that's not what this icon does.
So if you look at sort of again, app design
guidelines for navigation, this button should
take you to the home of the app.
>>Fred: The home of the application, yeah.
>>Reto: Exactly.
And once you're home, you shouldn't, that
basically that button should then become inactive.
It shouldn’t do anything.
It certainly shouldn't pop up a dialog.
>>Fred: So, say if it's associated with the
"save" action, it should really belong to
the right hand side of the action bar, where
you know, where typically people put you know,
any action related items.
>>Reto: yeah.
>>Fred: Or action items.
>>Reto: Indeed.
[laughs] I'd go a step further and say that
what you probably wanna do is, let's see,
do we have touch enabled?
We do.
So I would make this a touch target for clicking.
So that you click on that and it may actually
work.
No, so you click on that.
And that will let you modify the title.
Saving.
>>Fred: Oh.
Yeah.
>>Reto: Saving should just happen.
So this is the same as the previous app.
>>Fred: Right.
>>Reto: You shouldn't have to explicitly do
something in order to start saving your work.
It should just start saving it straight away.
>>Fred: Yeah, initially this text or string
should probably say "Untitled" or something.
>>Reto: Untitled one, untitled two.
>>Fred: Right.
>>Reto: Same way that text pad or notepad
works in Mac.
>>Fred: Yeah.
Definitely.
And change this to your app icon which brings
you to, back to the home screen.
>>Reto: So what happens, so, I guess if we
hit plus.
>>Fred: Sorry, I just hit back and then it
brought me back to
>>Reto: and then it exited out.
Because I was wondering, I was looking at
this
>>Fred: not exit button.
>>Reto: Sorry.
[laughs] So I was looking at this and I was
wondering to myself, OK, how do I get a list
of all of my notes?
'Cause I know plus is gonna let me add a new
note.
Um, so now I have two notes.
So how do I view them?
I'm guessing maybe "folder" so yeah, hitting
the folder button shows me a list.
Now, particularly on tablets, I feel like
that should be something which we can have
on the side.
So we have a list of all of our notes and
then a list view on the side.
And then whichever one we're currently working
on appearing next to it.
Rather than having almost two separate screens.
>>Fred: Right, time to read up on fragments
on Android.
>>Reto: Absolutely.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
Now as far as how you would do that for a
phone, I would probably have this as your
home screen.
So I like the idea of the first time you open
it when you have no notes, of opening it to
sort of that screen where you can start typing
straight away.
Once you have multiple notes, it would be
nice to be able to return to a home screen
which had that list so that you're able to
choose from and for me, intuitively hitting
back from any particular note should take
you to that list of notes.
>>Fred: yeah, definitely.
Now on the folder screen I would say the implementation
of this button,
>>Reto: Mm-hum.
>>Fred: is appropriate.
>>Reto: Humm.
>>Fred: Because you have an up affordance
where you bring it back to the sort of, but
hierarchically, this should be in the home
screen.
>>Reto: that's kind of the other way around.
>>Fred: And if you go back up, it doesn't
really make sense.
>>Reto: [laughs] Exactly.
>>Fred: Because supposedly this is the topmost
level of your application.
>>Reto: Right.
Indeed.
So I think what we would suggest is that you
switch these around.
So that when you're in a particular note,
you have the up affordance over here.
And then once you hit back then you just have
this which becomes your home screen.
>>Fred: Right.
Right.
>>Reto: So it would be interesting to know
why you went the way you did.
But that's, I think that's our general guidance
in terms of navigation.
>>Fred: Yeah, also I would go back to the
note editing screen and I would say, looking
at this folder icon, intuitively doesn’t
really tell me that, OK, it would bring me
to the list of notes.
>>Reto: Hmm.
>>Fred: Rather, I thought when I first looked
at it, it would open up previous note.
A previous note rather than this thing of
all available notes.
>>Reto: That's interesting.
See I saw it and thought to myself, this will
let me tag or file this note in a particular
folder.
>>Fred: Oh, right.
Yeah.
>>Reto: So, ambiguity is not your friend.
Alright, let's move on real quick.
Lets' have a look at the next app which is
Papyrus.
Which I think you were having a
>>Fred: Papyrus.
>>Reto: Look at earlier today.
>>Fred: Alright, let's read through it.
Have you read through the license agreements?
>>Reto: Absolutely.
>>Fred: Click accept?
>>Reto: Yes.
>>Fred: Cool?
>>Ian: [shouting] No, we don't want to accept
that!
>>Reto: Uh, what?
Oh.
>>Fred: Ian, what?
[laughter]
>>Reto: Just bar the door, don't let that
legal guy in.
>>Fred: Do we have any lawyers in this room?
Um.
So yeah, I mean, you're
>>Reto: This is interesting.
>>Fred: At first launch you're greeted by
"Welcome to Papyrus."
And a bunch of overlaid instructions.
Which tends to be a pretty popular way of
showing to your users you know, how do we,
how exactly to use your apps.
Although, a lot of the icons illustrated here,
are sort of make sense.
To me.
Right.
>>Reto: Hm.
Pretty intuitive.
But it's nice to have that.
>>Fred: So you have [indistinct] very intuitive.
>>Reto: That guide right off the bat.
>>Fred: I think that's great.
So you can just slide through it.
So you can change colors.
Do the erase.
>>Reto: Nice.
>>Fred: Tool picker.
Color.
>>Reto: So the only, this is all quite nice.
The only thing which I would say here is it
would be nice to be able to skip this entirely.
>>Fred: Good point.
>>Reto: So it's like, I've used this before,
I've installed it on a different device so
I don't need to go through it tall.
SO having a close or dismiss button next to,
you know.
>>Fred: Yeah
>>Reto: At every stage.
I think might be quite nice.
>>Fred: Yeah, it's got like five to six different
steps.
>>Reto: Yeah.
>>Fred: So it would be good.
So what's new?
>>Reto: What's new?
So this is interesting.
So I see where you're coming from here.
But I think this, even on a tablet but any
sort of mobile device, it's kind of annoying.
Like I know you guys have worked really hard
to build these new features.
But it's just another button that I have to
press before I can start using the app.
>>Fred: Right.
And chances are, in Google Play, you have
a place where you can put what's new.
>>Reto: Exactly.
>>Fred: So use that.
Take advantage of that.
>>Reto: Exactly.
So by all means, have it as an overflow button
item or something.
But you'll notice here that we just wanna
get to this app so that we can you know, talk
a little bit about it in the two minutes we
have remaining.
And I think so far we've had to swipe or press
like seven or eight times.
I don't have an active pen.
So this is the layout that we were talking
about before hand with sort of your tablet
layout with your list on the left and your
items on the right.
>>Fred: Three top level items where you can
get notebook.
So notebook is a collection of notes.
>>Reto: Notes.
>>Fred: That's how I, understand it.
>>Reto: OK.
So they've used sort of the more traditional,
well not more traditional, but like the first
app we looked at, sort of this notepad styling.
So that we can start typing.
>>Fred: See, does it draw?
>>Reto: Oh, this is a draw.
>>Fred: Oh, [indistinct] So you just draw
stuff.
Whoa.
It's using two fingers.
>>Reto: Oh that's interesting.
It's letting you zoom and pan.
>>Fred: Zoom.
Yep.
>>Reto: that's interesting.
>>Fred: That's good.
Let's get a different color.
Draw something else.
Cool.
>>Reto: Now I think, I have a vague recollection.
Let's see, zoom in.
If I go [pause] No, OK.
I thought maybe it was gonna do some fancy
recognition.
>>Fred: [indistinct]
>>Reto: But no.
Well, [indistinct].
Exactly.
>>Fred: yeah, exactly.
Alright.
[laughter]
>>Fred: So as far as title of the notes, I
think this app has implemented what we just
suggested.
>>Reto: Yeah, exactly.
>>Fred: Where initially here, there's no name
associated with this note.
Where if you type on it, you can type, you
can input the name of the note.
I don't know if I spelled it wrong.
Or spelled it right.
OK?
>>Reto: OK, yes.
So what have we got on the menu?
Share, page settings.
So we're gonna quickly check to see if share
works the way we want it to work.
It does.
Excellent.
>>Fred: Awesome.
And they have the up affordance here.
Which brings you back to the main screen of
the application.
But the screen shot, with a screen shot
>>Reto: It's quite nice.
>>Fred: [inaudible]
>>Reto: So we can just start things which
show up in the start list.
So that's, that's all pretty good.
>>Fred: Yeah, I'd like to compliment also,
the developer has implemented dragging.
>>Reto: Oh nice.
>>Fred: Drag and drop.
>>Reto: nice bit of drag and drop.
>>Fred: With your notes, to
>>Reto: Oh that's very nice.
>>Fred: So drag and drop was first introduced
I believe in Honeycomb, yeah?
>>Reto: I'd say.
>>Fred: But so far I haven't seen a lot of
apps taking advantage of it.
So, if you're watching
>>Reto: Yeah, this is nice.
So thank you nicely done
>>Fred: You can see them using it.
>>Reto: Alright, we are, we are running out
of time.
And I wanna make sure we have enough time
for Dan and Ian to get prepared for the Friday
review of games.
I think the last thing I would like to mention
about this app is I think the
[brief musical tones]
The, uh, the only real problems, I like the
layout.
I like the start.
I like the navigation.
The only real problem I had is that to get
started, to get that first note written, I
had to keep tapping a hundred different things,
you know.
I had to get through the tutorial.
I had to get through what's new, I had to
say I didn't have an active sync pen.
Had to then hit new notebook, which I had
to give a name to.
Then hit new note.
Which I had to give a name to.
So by the time we actually get to typing something
the first time, I'm bored and I just wanna
go and do something else.
>>Fred: Right, what you're saying is that
there are impatient users out there.
>>Reto: Yeah, that's me.
>>Fred: Right, me too.
>>Reto: Right.
I'm representative.
>>Fred: Me too.
>>Reto: In fact, the notebook I have on my
computer is always the simplest one available
on the system.
Notepad, text pad, I just wanna be able to
hit the icon, have it start really, really
quickly, and start typing something and not
even have to hit "save".
So that's kind of the experience that I'm
looking for.
Now all of the other things here, are a great
bonus.
But you wanna have the ability to just write
something really, really quickly.
But I don't know, what do you think?
So in summary, I think this is probably my
favorite of the three we've looked at, yeah?
>>Fred: Oh yeah.
Definitely.
Yeah.
Same.
>>Reto: very cool, so nicely done, Papyrus.
Good piece of work.
And to the other two apps as well.
Definitely no shame there.
So it's nice implementations and certainly
some different approaches.
But hopefully some of the advice we've given
will help you to tighten it up a little bit
and create something even better.
>>Fred: Alright.
>>Reto: Anything you wanna add?
>>Fred: No, that's all.
>>Reto: Well good, perfect.
So next week we're gonna be looking at news
apps.
So if you have an app that delivers the news,
please put it into the Moderator page, and
we will go through and handpick a selection
which we think would be interesting to look
at and talk about.
>>Fred: That's great.
>>Reto: So we'll sign off for today.
Oh, Ian.
>>Ian: well, I was just gonna say, why don't
you tell the people at home what they can
do to put their apps in the Moderator?
>>Reto: What they can do?
Oh, of course.
Thank you Ian.
>>Ian: How do they do it?
>>Reto: Very discreet.
So once you find the link and you go to the
appropriate Moderator page and you find the
appropriate category which is going to be
by week, what I want you to do then is put
in a brief description of your app.
But most importantly, and I think this is
what Ian was very subtly alluding to, we need
to have a link to the app in, placed in the
Google Play Store.
And we also would like you to include a link
to your Google plus profile.
So that can be the one of the developers,
designers, or if you've got a plus page, for
your app, so much the better.
We wanna try and make sure that the developers
of all of these apps get a chance to join
us in these hangouts and discuss their apps
and receive that feedback one to one.
So we need a way to be able to get in touch
and schedule those hangouts with you.
>>Fred: that's right.
>>Ian: those Moderator pages are open now.
And they will close the Wednesday before the
Friday review so that we have a couple days
to look at the apps before we review them.
>>Fred: Good point.
>>Reto: Terrific.
Thank you very much Ian.
Alright, so there's gonna be more of Ian in
just a few minutes.
So we're gonna sign off and we'll see you
next week, next Friday at one o'clock when
we're looking at news apps.
>>Fred: Alright.
See you next time.
>>Reto: So thank you for joining us.